I max has its own sound system that's
very cool I mean it's more aggressive
than a lot of theaters have they have a
high top center speaker which is
different from any other theater
configuration so we have to do slight
tweaks to take advantage of that which
is good in this movie because we have
sequences that involve height I think
that what one of the bonuses you get
with imax beyond the if you actually
shoot in imax and presented and i'm
actually get an amazing picture quality
but they also have a really thorough
sound system the sound is more envelope
in an IMAX theater than it is in many
theaters I love it I think anything that
gets people to go to the theater for a
reason I'm all in favor of I love the
fact that I max is like an event venue
you know it's not just like I'm not just
going to the movies I'm going to see
something in imax and that's what's
really fun and it's sort of missing some
showmanship these days you know that
that idea of showmanship it seems to be
missing and something like I max seems
to be the one thing that's still around
that is trying to do that they just want
you to experience something huge big and
that's that's I think really honest and
I like that